13 Marines no longer with us and you
don't even have the decency to show them
the basic respect anyway here with
reaction gold star father Darren Hoover
gold star motherin-law Christy shamblin
is with us and gold star mother Cheryl
Rex um first my deepest condolences um
as a parent uh I I I I can't think of
anything worse I I I I'm sure all three
of you would agree you're never going to
be the same person again is is that
pretty much the consensus
very much so yeah my understanding is
and and maybe I'll ask you Darren first
all three of you were part of a group
that were invited to meet with Donald
Trump last week and I I want to ask uh I
know there were efforts that you would
meet with President Biden uh and I my
understanding is nothing ever came of
that and Donald Trump trump read and
heard about that and he invited all the
families is that true so all the
families that were in DC at the time
with the exception of one so that made
eight of the 13 families um yes we were
invited to bedminister and we did go um
and President Biden did say no he
neglected to say anything um but
president Trump took us in and was very
gracious and listened to our
concerns and told us all that he would
take care of it were he to get into
office and that stuff like this can't
ever happen again and it shouldn't I
mean the failures on every level through
the administration the Pentagon DOD what
have you all the way down have failed us
and failed our kids
miserably and you lost your son Taylor
Hoover Marine Corps uh staff sergeant uh
31 years old uh lost in Afghanistan on
the 2 6 and our prayers by the way are
with you and your whole family uh Cheryl
you uh are the mother of Dylan
marola uh and and Dylan Lance corporal
US Marine died he was 20 years old this
day
um uh I don't know how you recover from
that to be honest Cheryl uh I'm sure
your heart to this day is broken what
was your reaction watching you know uh
Joe Biden checking his watch every two
seconds
as stated it took a lot for us not to
yell out um and call him out while we
were there it was Major disrespect to
all of us and our
families
um that wasn't the first time he was
rude to us he was rude to us while he
was in the room with us he made the
entire situation about himself he came
up to me inide of that he knew how I
felt how does he know how I
feel
well he's falsely claimed that his son
came back in a flag draped coffin that
is not how his son Bo died his son died
of cancer why would he tell a lie like
that I'm not sure he compared his son's
death to
r13 and he said that he brought his son
home in a flag draped coffin and that he
knew how he felt and there was no
comparison yeah christe you're the you
were the Mother-in-law you lost your
daughter-in-law uh Nicole G um and she
was a marine cor Sergeant 23 years old
uh you described the feeling that day at
Dober Air Force Base as being and
feeling disrespected and you said they
didn't even seem to know our story they
didn't know Nicole's names our names but
the military people did they knew the
names of everybody what I mean why
wouldn't the commander-in-chief know
that the name of your daughter-in-law
and all the and all the Sons and
Daughters of of people that lost their
their young family members and service
members I continue to be confused by
that um and again I'll say the military
the Marine Corps the people that wear
cammies knew our story very well they
knew who my daughter-in-law was they
showed an immense amount of respect and
care and um that that was not the
sentiment I have felt from our
Administration let me ask all three of
you what would you say Darren if you had
an opportunity right now this moment to
talk to President Biden what do you want
to tell him you know I've thought long
and hard about this Sean
I i' tell him how dare he how dare he
put our kids in that kind of a place to
not be able
to do their jobs with to the best of
their abilities I mean my goodness our
our Marines our sailors our soldiers our
Airmen are the tip of the spear for for
this country how dare he there's
absolutely no excuse and for him to
continue to not even say our kids' names
or have any mention of it is another
great disrespect as far as I'm concerned
I
just there's a lot I'd like to say
but Cheryl how about you um I would tell
him
how much he disrespected everybody that
was placed in that situation it wasn't
just about our 13 it was all of them he
didn't just put our kids in in harm he
killed Afghan civilians men women and
children who worked with us for 20 years
he's a major
disgrace wow Christie what would you
tell
him I would say that he as parents sent
the best we have and our Marines our
Airmen our soldiers our Sailors are the
best this country has and they deserve
respect and we deserve the best that our
Administration has and we haven't
received that yet and I hope that you
know it will come yeah I can't begin to
understand all the pain all of you have
been through I just pray for all of you
that that you know God give you the
peace and Grace that that you need to
overcome I think one of the biggest
challenges anybody can have in life and
thank you for telling you story it this
never should have happened and he should
have known and he should have cared more
no excuse for that at all thank you all
for being with us our prayers are with
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else